[Music]
[Applause]
all right everybody let's finish up with
something I found online that really
captures the holiday spirit this is what
I'm
liking so this time of year all over
America people put on their Jolly red
outfits to take part in one giant pub
crawl I love America the tradition is
known as Santa Con and it's totally fun
but not exactly kid-friendly that's why
a New York teen launched her own holiday
event elfcon instead of Santa's people
dress up as elves and instead of going
to bar to bar attendees hit the best hot
chocolate spots in town which is a
really good idea even to maybe marry
those worlds but whatever uh we have the
founder on the line now watching on NBC
New York say hi to Sophie everybody
what's up
Sophie Hi hi so Sophie how did this all
start yeah so I attended SantaCon for
several years when I was younger with my
dad and it was always was pretty fun
because we had that great sense of
community um but I could never fully
participate because you know I was
underage you know fast forward to
January of 2021 during covid I was
longing for a similar sense of community
and I was talking with my dad and I was
saying how great would it be if there
was a familyfriendly version of Santa
Con you know maybe elves instead of
Santa's hot chocolate instead of beer
and you know maybe we call it elfcon and
he encouraged me to go for it and I did
and I'm really really glad that I did
that's amazing so it's not just for fun
though right you're actually like
raising awareness of money right yeah so
we like to think of ourselves as the
anti- SantaCon because you know elves
instead of Santas and hot chocolate
instead of deer but we are a charity
organization so for the past two years
and this year we're going to be donating
to the Trevor Project and the making
Headway Foundation which are two
wonderful organizations that both
support the well-being of kids the
Trevor Project Pro with lgbtq plus Youth
and the making Headway foundation with
families of children with brain tumors
um and over the past two years we've
been able and fortunate enough to donate
$5,000 to them with over 250 tickets
sold and so we're really really excited
to do so again this year and we like to
show people that you can have fun and
you know do good too and kids helping
kids um and so we just hope everyone
will join us it's our third year and
we're really really excited it'll
hopefully be the best one yet I'm so
proud of you man this is super
cool you can have a good time without
alcohol absolutely so thank you Sophie
I'm liking your post right now
right thank you all right and that's not
all girl our season long partner pilot
pin makers of precise the go-to pin of
the Kelly Clarkson show want to honor
truly Unstoppable people just people
with great ideas like yourself so
they're going to be writing you a check
for $1,000 how's that
sound oh my God thank you so much
absolutely absolutely have so much fun
at Alcon this year thank you to all our
guests this hour Jimmy Fallon Megan
Trainer Matt Jaden La Daran and
Christina Perry and I want to give a
special thanks to our friends at Balon
her they create the most beautiful
realistic Christmas trees and Decor as
you can see from up on our set have a
great day y'all if it's not try and
change
[Music]
it
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home